any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so today we are joined with a phenomenal
writer a
deep thinker and someone who is
incredibly astute about the history of
astronomy and physics and has profiled
one of the titans of
of all time astronomy but in particular
the last 50 or so years and that's
ashley yeager who's joining us all the
way from north carolina
ashley how are you doing today thank you
for joining us
thank you so much for having me um i am
i'm super excited to be here and i
look forward to talking about dark
matter and vera rubin and the history of
astronomy these are all things that i've
been
reading and thinking about since i did
my graduate work so i'm excited to to
share more yes and you are a renowned
writer and member of the scientific
writing community but also
also an expert on the topic on the
subject matter and i always like to
begin my episodes with authors who are
joining me
honor me by coming on like yourself is
play a game called ignoring advice so
the advice that we always get right
ashley is don't judge a book by its
cover why would you do that but you know
in my in in most cases it's the one
thing that you have to go on how do you
know the book is good unless you know
the author um you know she he or he has
written something before i hadn't done
that and the uh and the publisher
wouldn't let me or most authors really
touch the cover
but uh this is an mit press another mit
press uh smash soon to come out and i
just wanted to play that little game
with you how'd you come up with the
title what's the idea behind the cover
and the subtitle
of this fascinating new book
yeah we played around a lot with the
title
my working title
was all the matter we cannot see
which is kind of a take on one of my
favorite books all the light we cannot
see
um but
there you know there were some questions
about we wanted to get vera in the title
we wanted to get dark matter in the
title and so we were thinking about the
book that she had written her collection
of essays um called bright galaxies dark
matters and so as we started to think
about the title we're like well maybe we
can
use that and kind of go beyond that and
that's what we did adding and beyond um
to to really kind of explore
what else
about her life wasn't really covered in
that book and also then
explained that in the subtitle of the
life of astronomer group ruben just
talking about her life and kind of what
made her
unique and and really what set of
principles she lived by that i think we
can all
take away from the book and try to apply
in our own lives
and uh not only can you hold up the
front cover i have not received my copy
yet i am going to buy a copy but i'm
also expecting a free copy because on
the very back there may be and i love
that picture of her she's such a like i
don't know what do you call a female
stud she's just such a badass i just
love her so much i regret that i didn't
get to meet her i talked about her a lot
in my book my first book um but i want
to know uh especially the back cover if
someone happens to judge the back cover
what will they find there so on the back
uh there are three endorsements one
lovely one by you and i can go ahead and
read that if you'd like to i i was very
i haven't seen it in three months so
i was so flattered um it says a
mesmerizing and worthy compliment to
ruben's own bright galaxies dark matters
jaeger's tendered portrait illuminates
the scientific soul of one of history's
most brilliant navigators of the heavens
and which i think is just beautiful
because it is so true i mean she
she was just an incredible scientist an
incredible person and she really did
show us how
beautiful space can be when we stopped
to take a look at it
so talk about vera rubin as a scientist
what did you learn about her what's her
heroine's journey you know kind of the
obstacle she faced the people she met
along the way
and how she returned with the magic
elixir you know like like luke skywalker
does you know this classic story of the
hero's journey uh i found resonant
throughout uh throughout your your
wonderful new book so so talk about her
her challenges her story her struggles
early on and how she resolved them for
our benefit
yeah well i think what was really
interesting was she was in a family that
was very supportive of her
curiosity and so
her parents really fostered that and
they let her you know they didn't love
that she stayed up at night and looked
at the stars out the window but she she
did and so
they were very
encouraging and actually took her to
some amateur astronomy meetings in
washington dc where she grew up
and so i think she had the sense that
this was something that she was
passionate about something that she
could do
but being in school in in the 1930s
1940s
you know women weren't really encouraged
to do science and math um so
you know there's this lovely story where
she wants to take a drafting class and
she has to go to the boy's wing
to do that and and so she does you know
and so
i think that's kind of the beginning of
where she starts to experience some of
these challenges
in terms of understanding well there
might be some pushback but i'm just
going to continue to do what i do and
even in high school her her physics
teacher wasn't the most supportive he
was you know he basically said as long
as you stay away from physics you'll be
fine and when you go to college well she
majored in astronomy so
didn't take his advice
and so i think you know she had over and
over again kind of different people
telling her hey you shouldn't be doing
this and what i found
really refreshing and also a good
reminder was
rather than listening to those people
she would find people who did support
her um and so you know as she goes on
she meets her husband
um robert rubin and he is also a
scientist excuse me um and so she
you know she and he talk about
different physical principles they they
talk about different papers that come
out and and he really
encourages her and and you know she had
applied to go to grad school she got
into harvard but decided she wanted to
be with him so she goes to cornell
and again faces people who
are not super supportive but you know he
kind of helps her read different papers
you know this particular one by george
gamau about you know does the universe
rotate and then she has another mentor
martha starr who helps her start to
collect
different data sets to be able to
investigate that question and
and then again she goes on and presents
that um at the american astronomical
society meeting and uh you know get some
blow back there i think people were
pretty
um
surprised by her findings um essentially
that she found this kind of unexplained
motion that potentially could be
interpreted as the universe rotating
um and so i think that startled a lot of
people
um but there were always one or two
people who did encourage her and even
george gammell himself reached out
and said i was really fascinated by your
paper you know what what are you working
on could
you know would you be interested in
questions that i had and so then she
ends up doing her phd and obviously i'm
simplifying the story here it sounds
much neater and tidy than it really is
yeah yeah but i mean ultimately then she
continues she just keeps persevering she
ends up at uc san diego and works with
the verbiages and i know you wanted to
talk a little bit about that
so i can um you know we can we can talk
about how influential they were they
kind of really got her started giving
her some of the tools to then go on to
do
the the bigger projects that would lead
to her providing evidence for dark
matter
and when i think about you know her
struggles and you know of course being a
woman and in that epoch and still even
to this day uh women suffer you know
have have more challenges i would say
than than most men do and and other
minorities as well but uh but certainly
back then
and she was you know one thing if i had
to summarize her personality it was like
courage and
just because she was never one to like
use her
her kind of the the penalties the
challenges she had as an obstacle she
kind of like leaned into them as we'd
say nowadays or the stoic you know the
obstacle is the way sort of mentality um
talk about that what she always seems
like a peaceful warrior at least until
her husband died and you talk very
touchingly about that at the book you
know spoiler alert i mean she's not
alive anymore i don't think we can spoil
that too much but um
that relationship her father and also
her husband as as playing this role and
also ken ford who who often gets lost i
think you know unfortunately because her
story is so powerful but you bring him
to light so talk about these men in her
life and and what contributions they
made and then we'll talk about margaret
burbidge my late great colleague
yeah
sure
um yeah so i mean i think her her father
her husband ken ford these were all
people who saw potential and saw how
curious that she was and really wanted
to foster that and really support her
and
i mean i i just i don't think they ever
said oh well you're a woman so you can't
do that it was just you're an equal
you have
amazing brain capacity let's explore
that let's figure out what you are
curious about and
and use that to
continue to explore the world i mean i
think that was something else that that
those three in particular also had right
her father was very curious about things
how things worked her husband was very
curious about how things worked and you
know kent ford was always kind of
pressing the limits how can we
get more information from the tele
telescopes how can we gather more light
what what can we do what can we push
forward and i think
those combined forces really
helped her excel in that
they were aligned with what she wanted
to do they were aligned with her ability
to be very curious and ask these
different questions and then pursue them
until
you know all else fails right just
really going after trying to get answers
right
and another interesting vignette which i
didn't know about her is what she did
during world war ii can you talk about
her activities during world war ii her
patriotic duties and and the other
things that consumed her attention at
that time
yeah so
um she was working in a service office
doing a lot of paperwork
and that was i think
one of those critical moments that she
had and maybe other people have when
they realize
something that they don't want to do
so she her
high school job was in the summers and
and when she was free was to basically
file papers
and whether they were were related to
the war i don't know for sure but um it
was just something that she
got up every day rode the bus with her
dad went into the office filed her
papers left but the whole time she was
thinking about the stars and thinking
about astronomy and she just had this
memory of
saying to herself this is not what i
want to do
how do i really go after what i do want
to do so that i don't have to spend my
life
being kind of um
complacent or i hate to say bored that's
probably not the right word but just not
maximizing her capacity and kind of
really fueling her curiosity
and i was unaware of her connection to
richard feynman can you talk about that
yes yeah
there's a a lovely anecdote
that you know she had had this crutch on
mr feynman and he had come to vassar but
she was a little bit too
shy to talk to him
and so then
her parents had actually arranged dinner
with
robert reuben's parents they they both
lived in the same building and
so she went to dinner and they were
talking and she had asked about um
richard feynman and
robert rubin you know just very
kind of coolly and in his very calm not
bragging way was like oh i'm a student
of his and so that kind of pete uh vera
rubin's attention she was like oh that's
very interesting and then um she
actually joined robert at vasser or i'm
sorry at cornell and
richard feynman was one of those allies
that she had she was having trouble with
her astronomy supervisor
and
you know richard feynman stepped in and
said as her physics advisor you know
well if you need to teach a course for
this other
advisor you know maybe we can flip the
order of how you do the sequence of
physics classes and so
again i think that was someone kind of
looking out for her and figuring out how
can we help her rather than how do we
hold her back
cornell continued the rich tradition
with the baton passed on
from
vera to jill tarter past guest on the
show
i think she was her main name was
cornell even so she has an even deeper
cornell connection
uh but um what's fascinating about vera
and that early work which again you know
you're to be congratulated i thought i'm
an expert you know i wrote about vera in
my book and i studied her in depth and
you know she missed out on the nobel
prize so many times um
and uh and in fact we had a competition
for you know on my website when the book
was launched who you know really should
we petition the nobel committee on
change.org you know to basically you
know force them to give it a nobel prize
to even posthumously and and vera was
number one and then not posthumously and
thank god is uh jocelyn bell burnell and
i'm happy to say she's coming on my show
on uh december 10th which is the day
they award the nobel prizes uh and
that's great
but uh when i think about what vera was
doing at this time again the courage
because uh and and kind of the the the
mystery of science the serendipity of
science comes through in this book she
was working on a rotating universe which
originally at least in my conception and
my limited knowledge goes back to kurt
gertle of all people yeah i thought the
universe was rotating and and of course
then startlingly you know she finds not
that the universe is rotating and has
the courage to go forward with the uh
falsification of that claim which girdle
you know had put forth and then gamov
had championed some years later um but
then she finds other things are rotating
courtesy of colleagues here at san diego
but but first let's talk about the
rotating model because
i want to know what are some of the
fascinating aspects of that model why
did people take it even seriously and
and just to connect to another mystery
uh that was also involved a female titan
of astronomy in the name of henrietta
swan levitt you know there were people
in the late 1800s early 1900s who
thought they saw andromeda rotating and
it was rotating really fast and that
meant it had to be really close so that
was a false start this twisted this
twisting universe was a false start but
i think it's instructed because it led
to these future developments talk about
the rotating universe what what
captivated vera about that model
yeah i think what captivated her was
kind of this this
idea that
a lot of things rotate right planets
rotate around the sun
um we now know that stars rotate around
the galaxy and and you have these groups
of galaxies that rotate around each
other and so
her broader question kind of fueled by
gamma and some of the other galaxy work
that she had started to do was well if
you have all of these other smaller
structures rotating
is it
can we ask the question why wouldn't the
universe rotate
why wouldn't it follow a similar
principle and and so i think that was
kind of the the great mystery that
really drew her in there was
you had all these other examples of
things in the universe that were had
this you know spinning motion and and so
she just wanted to know on a larger
scale does that hold up do do you see
that with the entire universe which i
think
is kind of a fantastical idea when you
think about it i mean it's hard to wrap
your mind around it but when you start
to think about the logic that she and
others
used it's not super far-fetched um and
so like she did she was like well i have
this question and so now i'll go out and
i'll try to gather some data and
whatever the data tells me that's what
i'll i'll go with as my conclusion so
yeah i always point out that you know we
physicists have mathematician envy in
that girdle showed the limits of
mathematics that you could there were
closed formal systems who were you know
causally incomplete you could not
logically you know derive the
prove things from a limited set of
axioms that were self-consistent he also
found a contradiction in the us
constitution
and that einstein instructed him don't
mention that when you go for your
immigration hearing right not going to
hear that you found a logical flaw in
the us constitution but you can still
maintain this thing that karl popper you
know would rail against later that you
know kind of unfalsifiable versus
falsifiable and in her case she actually
you know was kind of over and done with
it once it once it proved that it was
really not viable she and gamma 2 to his
credit moved on but um but girdle never
did in fact i get emails all the time
and people send me things about the
rotating universe and that's what that's
what girdle was talking about on his
deathbed it has all sorts of weird
properties that you can have these
closed time-like curves so that time is
basically cyclical and and repeats
itself on big enough time scales uh but
the other thing i get from from heirs of
of people like uh like gamov and and
like um herman and as well as um you
know conversations with people who are
related to this wiki family i get this a
lot actually how dare you promote you
know this this notion that vera
discovered dark matter that's just a
plot and it always comes and they're
probably listening and you know god
bless them
but they say it's just the plot and do
you know where they say the plot
originated ashley uh no i actually don't
they call it a vassar college plot
oh my okay
so vassar college is somehow scheming
the cabal that makes up vassar according
to wiki's own i think it's his daughter
and uh so do you get any have you have
you uh you know encountered any of this
before kind of the pushback from
zwicky's family about the claims of
reuben as you know the fo founder of
dark matter etc obviously he had he
coined the term
um
well i
i have gotten some
criticism i i don't we'll see what
happens when the book comes out there
might be more
but um i
i've been writing about vera since 2008
i i wrote some pieces after she sadly
passed away and i think that was
kind of when some of this criticism came
out because there were so many stories
about her work
um
and i i hadn't heard about the cabal
that's that's very interesting um
but i i also think i'm afraid you will
yeah i'm afraid that there will be more
criticism and i i mean i i'll i'll hear
it i you know i i don't know i tried to
do some research into the origin of
actual
dark matter where does that term come
from and it was very interesting zuwiki
did play a part in it in his studies of
galaxy clusters and so i don't want to
take that away from him
but there were people talking about
dark matter or invisible things in the
sky
before he said that and um
i i talk a little bit about that in my
book and kind of where the actual term
dark matter comes from and so that was
actually surprising to me as well
knowing that this conversation
was going on before he used the term
related to um the galaxy clusters that
he was studying so
it's definitely definitely another facet
that makes vera's story very interesting
so um and then you know i think that the
mystery of of dark matter of course was
very perplexing but maybe we can talk
about how vera first learned the
technology the tools etc which um as i
learned in my research for for
on her was was really you know kind of
nurtured here at uc san diego not
through telescopes that we have but
through the partnership and relationship
she had with jeff and margaret burbidge
sadly both now deceased uh margaret only
uh passed away last year just after
100th birthday
and you know margaret was was i i
remember her very distinctly different
than jeff uh and in fact she was kind of
uh really she she didn't fit the mold i
don't think she really would would would
necessarily be the best role model for
like advocating you know special
emphasis on women in astronomy because
she famously rejected any award that had
to do with her gender her sex however
you phrase it and she um she was
vehemently opposed to such things on the
other hand she was also know overlooked
many times for very prestigious things
including the nobel prize and she was
the only astronomer on the famous bbfh
paper
that could really you know untangle and
get the data that eventually won willie
fowler a nobel prize well let's talk
about the technology the techniques that
she use and that and the collaboration
with ken ford so who is ken ford
kent ford
was an instrument builder he worked at
the department of terrestrial magnetism
in in dc or just outside of dc
and he had been there for a while he had
been working on this image tube
spectrograph which would really kind of
magnify the light coming in from the
telescope so you could you could see
much more red light and kind of get into
those wavelengths and so
he was there and just before vera moved
there she was out in um san diego and
working with the verbiages and and they
really showed her how a lot of the
intricacies of using the telescope
worked i think they you know they really
provided the training ground for her to
go to the telescope and use the film and
and learn how to change the film in and
out and and kind of do these different
steps that were necessary to to to make
these observations and then they also
showed her how to take spectra of
galaxies and stars in galaxies and and
be able to calculate the rotation of
those stars around the galaxy which then
she really
harnessed to be able to provide the
evidence for dark matter and so she had
all those skills she went back to dc
she had been at georgetown at the time
but she was having trouble juggling
family and observing and teaching and
kind of all of her other
responsibilities and i think she really
wanted to focus on observing and that
became clear working with the verbiages
and so
she went to the department of
terrestrial magnetism and asked for a
job and after a little bit of
deliberation they said okay and so on
her first day she came in and they had
set up two offices for her one either
with kent ford or one with bernard burke
who was a radio astronomer and
kent ford told me you know she moved in
with him and she never moved out and so
that started that kind of beautiful
collaboration between them where they
would go to the telescopes they would
use his
image tube spectrograph to
take these really
detailed observations of stars first in
andromeda and then other galaxies and
and be able to calculate how quickly
those stars were moving around the
galaxy
and you know at that point i think you
know she she obviously she discovered
this these effects with kent and
their collaboration but i think you know
learning about how the burbidges had
done the spectroscopy they'd use the
uh you know the telescopes in in uh
texas and other places um and then here
but you know really refining the kind of
tenuous spectroscopy
and and even coming close to discovering
you know aspects of the rotation curve
but it really took reuben
uh you know pushing on this and so what
was that struggle like what was the you
know kind of
key moment when when this was you know
convincing to everybody although again
you know not enough to convince the
nobel academy as i chastise them for but
um before it's too late maybe they can
you know rewrite their own kind of made
up silly rules against posthumous prizes
yeah when did you know what was that
like because i've heard it described by
people that lost the nobel prize etc
that one of the most important tools you
have as a scientist are pr tools and
then you must you must actually agitate
on your own behalf it's not enough to
let the science do the talking yeah
i think
what happened was there were lots of
different types of
observations going on in this space
there was some theoretical work and so
everything came together in the 70s to
really kind of coalesce and and the
astronomy community had to
to wake up and say oh my gosh we do have
this problem like
this is clearly showing us that most of
the matter that we're looking at is not
most of the matter in the universe and
so
in the in the 60s there were some radio
astronomy observations that suggested
rotation curves were flat then in the
70s you had viera's paper on andromeda
come out
and then early 70s you had some of this
theoretical work looking at how
galaxies would rotate over time and
whether they would describe disintegrate
or whether they would stay together and
the key in those simulations was you
really needed this
kind of halo of stuff
to keep the galaxies together and so i
think vera read that and
so many people had said you know maybe
flat rotation curves are only in
galaxies like andromeda or they're only
in these other types of galaxies and so
what she did which i think was really
brilliant is she
went after
making observations of stars rotating in
galaxies in all types of galaxies so it
didn't matter what type but she said
i'll look here and i'll look at this
type of galaxy and essentially by the
1980s
early 1980s
she had done a survey with kent ford and
another astronomer
and
all the rotation curves were flat and so
i think at that point and there's this
beautiful postcard that i found in her
archives
of um norbert thernard one of her
colleagues writing to her and saying
from a 1980
meeting
the theorists are finally beginning to
believe that the rotation curves are
flat and so to me that was a striking
moment i know there had been papers that
had come out a little bit before that
saying we have to address dark matter we
have to make sure that
we start to have these conversations it
does exist we need to start to figure
out what it is but i think
i think by that push in the 1980s early
1980s where you have
kind of all of that buy-in on those flat
rotation curves essentially that
all of the stars in a galaxy that are
the stars that are farther out are
moving at exactly the same speed as
stars closer in which isn't what you
would expect right you would expect that
the stars farther out would move
much more slowly around the galaxy and
so
i think seeing this in all of these
different types of galaxies and also
seeing it in visible wavelengths right
you're seeing this in the type of light
that we can see with our eyes i think
that was really convincing for
a lot of the astronomy community and and
you know you'll have different people
debate that but
i think that was a key moment um for
really kind of shifting
the the way people think about dark
matter and really trying to address okay
now that we've discovered that it exists
what is it
right
yeah i i love the story of how you know
this postcard comes in and yeah and so
forth and then she happens to be working
um with with her husband
on a project to determine who was the
first astronomer to measure the uh to
detect the crab nebula and that it was a
new star and what what you know who was
and i'm like thinking like imagine like
the wright brothers yeah in north
carolina where you are and they're
they're at kitty hawk and their planet
and then orville says let me let me see
if i can think of a new way to have
sugar-free cotton candy you know
probably something completely different
it's just so hilarious that they work
together yeah i'll get back to their
love affair and the daniel later on
obviously you know we know that that
he's no longer with us and neither is
she sadly um and but but the impact on
them you know and her as as just
you know because i i like to think you
know there's a famous quote from uh
ginger rogers you know that she had to
do everything that fred astaire did now
i don't even know if you know who these
people are i only know because my mom is
of a certain age and she was a huge fan
of fred astaire and ginger rogers but
nevertheless uh the point being you know
she always made this quip that you know
i had to do everything fred did but
backwards wearing high heels yeah i'm
thinking like she was doing all this and
oh by the way she had four kids
it's just unbelievable did you get to
meet any of them
i did not get to meet them in person i
did get to talk
over the phone and correspond by email
which was which was lovely um
and it was uh mainly alan rubin who's at
princeton right now he he was kind of
leading the correspondence there
with some of the other brothers chiming
in sadly judith died as well
and so
so they you know
they had very and a very interesting
perspective and it was good to hear the
stories from their perspective as well
because they were seeing some of these
things as children and
and so um
but it was just touching to see that
as
much as she as much as vera put into her
science she put that much passion into
raising her children and so it was
almost as i i wonder where she found the
energy for everything sometimes when i
think about everything that she
accomplished it it's just incredible i
mean and i guess that does speak to
having the right partner which she talks
about a lot and um and just being able
to
juggle all of that and um
really prioritize
when you focus on your family and when
you're focusing on your astronomy and
kind of how to how to integrate all of
that and i think she did both of those
extremely well
did she pivot again after the 1980s or
after kind of the you know the tie to
turn scientifically
did she or did she you know kind of
remain continuing this this
very precise and very accurate
measurements of dark matter yeah she did
a little bit um kind of going back to
the work about
looking at large-scale motion of
galaxies and and even kind of using some
of her work to find out other ways to
calculate the hubble constant
um so she
she did kind of follow where her
curiosity led
but i think
kind of later in the 1980s she went back
to
looking at galaxies i think she just
really liked
that type of research and being able to
go out and really
challenge the technology and say what's
the farthest star that i can find from a
center of a galaxy and she just that was
something that she continued to do
even into the 2000s well into her 70s
she was still going to the telescope
still looking for these really far out
stars to to see
do they do they still hold up that trend
do they move more quickly around the
galaxy than we would expect or does
their velocity drop off and
either way that was going to tell you
something fascinating about the galaxy
and and other galaxies right like she
had this question of do galaxies dark
matter halos touch each other are do
they extend far enough
that kind of galaxies are connected in
that way or do does the dark metal halo
drop off and so that's the question that
she was exploring even in 2007 and 2008
some of the last times that she went to
the telescope
and did she ever like connect the work
uh that she had done with cluster
dynamics and the stuff just to bring
full circle to where
um
that's wiki came in in other words you
know he kind of postulated this from the
viral theorem and the rotation of
galaxies inside of a cluster did she
ever make connections to the cluster
community or not really
i think
in just understanding the broader scope
of how influential dark matter is she
did
and then she did do some work like i
said kind of working on large-scale
structure but i don't know that she ever
did
a lot of research into
how different galaxies move in a cluster
and whether dark matter is involved in
that i think she was more focused on
individual galaxies when it came to that
question
and
um throughout the 80s and in the 90s
you know she did have some sorts of you
know kind of connection as a
public speaker and
and a uh advocate for for women and
other minorities can you talk about that
work as vera as advocate yeah
i think that started relatively early on
when she did see
how much
of a struggle she had to make to be
successful and i think she did recognize
that she had a lot of people helping her
and she wanted to be one of those people
who would help
others and so
she did that in her own individual
mentoring but then she also did that in
terms of
she was data driven so she and a couple
other women um
did some research in the night early
1970s looking at
you know pay rates for women astronomers
and where they landed positions and
um how many phds were graduating in the
70s versus the 40s and so
she was always kind of tracking
the progress and really speaking out
when
things weren't going well for women and
i can remember that she would always say
and even her sister said this that at
the national academies meetings they
just
everyone would kind of brace themselves
when she stood up because
she was going to talk about what are we
doing about the numbers of women in the
national academies and how are we going
to improve it and so i think
she was she was always aware of the
problem
and slowly started to talk about it but
then in the 1980s 1990s she really
started to push i think
maybe in part because her daughter faced
adversity even in her own
journey to become an astronomer and this
was you know 1970s 1980s and so i think
beer was thinking well wait a minute
this shouldn't exist now and it does and
what can we do about it how can we
continue to
to voice this frustration and push for
change
and what do you think you know where
some of the
you know modes of of doing so and and
advocating for change and and actually
measuring it because it's one thing to
do it and people talk about it but how
do you what by what metrics do we judge
the efficacy of outreach and and and and
you know basically accommodation of
underrepresenting right
i think she was tracking a lot in terms
of awards um how many awards were given
to women are is there equity in
awards that are solely for women versus
open to everyone
and you know again counting numbers in
the national academies counting numbers
in
the astronomy societies um looking at
numbers of phds and
and really even in her own mentees like
you know how many
women are there who are actually
interested in doing this and how do we
foster that how do we continue to let
them be successful and i think she had
something really interesting in her own
book
that i didn't quite get into in mind but
she said you know
we really shouldn't be interviewing the
women who are successful we should be
interviewing the women who aren't
successful and trying to figure out what
is it about
their story and their journey what
roadblock did they hit that
uh ultimately forced them out of the
field and i think that's something that
we can still do
yeah absolutely and as we kind of come
to the end of of her life i was thinking
we'd talk a little bit about
uh her relationship her love affair she
got married at what 19 years old
they traveled together you know she had
challenges you know basically like um
maria gephardt mayer who was a professor
here who she surely overlapped with um
you know that they couldn't get position
you know without their husbands as their
kind of uh leaders except here at san
diego that was true of hopkins and
argonne for for them uh and obviously
margaret got her position and jeff came
along as a spousal liar yeah he started
off at the center for astrophysics and
faith sciences
nevertheless their love affair in all
those cases was very very prominent
pronounced and yeah i wonder you know
can you speak a little bit about that
maybe from some the research that you
did with um uh with vera and her husband
and and what what basically you know uh
culminated in their very long and very
fruitful marriage
yeah
i i did have the opportunity to
interview both of them together
um in in 2007 and
it was
meeting them both together it was just
it was a stunning
bit of time that i will remember and
probably try to draw on for my own
relationships just the way they
interacted with each other they finished
each other's sentences they were so
respectful they were so loving and they
didn't have to say it you just felt it
right and even after all the years that
they had been together it was incredible
um
and i think a lot of it was that they
truly saw each other as equals you know
robert never thought that his career
should deserve more attention than
vera's career i mean he made career
choices to make sure
that she had options that she could go
and do her phd so he chose to go to
to move to to maryland
and work at one of the applied physics
labs so that vera could go on and do her
phd in washington dc
and and and throughout his series of
choices he always thought about her so
even going to uc san diego they moved to
san diego because
he had someone to work with he he you
know he had a sabbatical that he was
given and
he wanted to make sure that she had
someone to work with or
in the case of the verbiages a couple to
work with to really
drive her work and so i think
consciously he was always thinking about
what's best for her first and then how
does that fit in what with what's best
for me and and how can we both succeed
in making those decisions which i think
is something that's just ultimately um
something to really deeply consider
and then the last thing i want to ask
about is your own personal journey
you went uh you were at mit in their
very prestigious science uh writing uh
program there was that the night school
is that the name of it
um so they have two they have the night
um the night
uh i can't remember the exact name of it
but that's um for established career
journalists and then the graduate
program actually has a science writing
program and so that's the program that i
did was the graduate program in science
writing and
and so
we were asked to do a thesis and the
summer before i started at mit i worked
at the air and space museum
and and i had been walking through the
explore the universe exhibit there and
i had noted that there weren't very many
women in the exhibit
um you know there was caroline herschel
with my brother john and then as i
walked through then there was a placard
of vera and i had never heard of her
story i had never heard of dark matter
at that point oh wow and i just was
instantly curious and so i started
asking my supervisor david duvorkin a
lot of questions and he said well you
know i am working on bureau's oral
history would you like to help me and so
that kind of set me down that path
and then i that that carried on at mit
where we did this thesis and so that
kind of became the outline for the book
and all of these years later i won't say
how many um
it's finally come out so um so that was
kind of my
discovery of her story was just walking
around a museum and kind of taking note
of the different exhibits and and just
really being drawn to her story and who
she was and
and just how she had gotten into
astronomy
um
wonderful and the last question i had is
just one of curiosity i mentioned in my
in comium for your wonderful book you
know vera's own book um yeah how
influential is that because and how is
this book different from that in the
sense that i always view that as kind of
a book of essays rather than on
autobiography this is kind of a
biography
a scientific biography of her which is
sorely needed yeah
so i think
the
this biography is a good compliment that
i loved reading her collection of essays
there's so much in there
and and you you really feel her
personality in there you get a sense of
the work that she's done
but to me
i was left kind of wanting to piece
together her entire story like from
beginning to end which you can do in a
biography which is lovely so i really
wanted to bring her to life to really
show people
who she was what were the set of
principles that she lived by that made
her so successful
and really how can we take
those and and like i said apply them in
our own life what can we take away from
her story because it's not just about
being an astronomer it's about being
this beautiful human being who
really tried to to foster people's um
people's gifts and really encourage them
to be successful and
so i think
yeah and so what's the book builds on
her own story
sorry
yeah i was just going to say this is
going to on that yes
so what's next for you ashley what what
are you going to
turn your considerable talent and
intellect
i i haven't quite decided yet i came
across across a lot of incredible
astronomers in doing the research for
this book so
that might be some of what i write about
next i'm not exactly sure yet but i will
keep you posted
and whatever i come up with i will
definitely let you know and we can chat
more about
all of it and you are always welcome on
the into the impossible podcast i want
to
uh uh remind folks we've been talking
with ashley jean yeager who is associate
news editor at science news she has
written for quanta science news
nature astronomy skying telescope the
scientist other publications her book
was called by kirkus reviews which is
one of the most important
you know pre-publication
outlets there is a compelling life of a
top-notch scientist
and uh there is a blur by yours truly
which is uh done with all sincerity
about this wonderful book bright
galaxies dark matter and beyond the life
of astronomer
vera rubin ashley yeager thank you so
much it's been such a delight i've been
following you for years and i hope we
can continue to stay in touch yes
definitely thank you so much i
appreciate the opportunity
it's a pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
mmm
[Music]